libre et sans faire ce sont des extraits
de cet ouvrage qui ont servi de socle à
la conférence tenue par l'un des auteurs
de ce livre aux archives départementales
de la réunion bruno maillard kotor avec
frédéric régent et gildas gonfier
s'appuie sur les témoignages d'esclaves
jusqu'alors inexploités sont les
esclaves eux mêmes qui disent moi ce pas
cet ouvrage c'est ce qui est passionnant
c'est qu'au départ nous on avait
quelques exemples de sources qui nous
montrait que les états vos fonds n'était
pas si s'aliéner qu'on le pensait du pas
toujours des révoltés en puissance et
c'est à travers ces sources que l'on a
vu au fur et à mesure toutes ces
pratiques socialement solidaire ses
activités connues parallèle ses
expressions culturelles investissez que
ces stars ont construit sur ce monde
parallèle au total c'est à dire ces
moments où il n'ya pas de contraintes du
maître par exemple pendant les temps de
travail où ils se réunissent sur
l'habitation en dehors de l'habitation
et encore il fa préserve cette humanité
profonde grâce à ces dépositions ils ces
interrogatoires d'hommes de femmes et
d'enfants martinique en guadeloupe et à
la réunion
une autre vérité révélée sur cette
période les paroles d'esclaves dans les
colonies française du xviiie au 19e
siècle qui nous montrent un tout autre
visage de cette société période toujours
serbe doit aussi période qui doit aussi
montrer
et bien cette force et intelligence et
cet espoir que ces hommes et ces femmes
avaient ça c'est important de le soigner
ce qu'on va traverser archi voici
c'est ce combat qu'ils ont mené au
quotidien pour préserver l'humanité et
celle de leurs enfants
ce qui est important c'est de redonner
de l'humanité aux esclaves de l'humanité
dans le système colonial esclavagiste il
n'y en a pas - justement ce qui est
important c'est de voir comment ces
hommes et ces femmes
malgré la violence du système cette
coercition ultra présente sur les
habitations dans l'usiné va commencer à
semer ces femmes ont su se construire
les espaces appropriés des objets tisser
des relations pour justement préserver
les auteurs se sont appuyés sur des
registres précieux très bien conservés à
l'image des documents des archives
départementales de la règle sans les
fillettes écrit par une martinique et un
good hope et un réunionnais et donc qui
recoupe les trois champs donc on a
utilisé nos archives propre même s'il ya
des archives commune aux archives
nationales d'outre-mer d'aix aux
archives départementales on a beaucoup
de séries bus et deux qui est
extrêmement terme à préserver
si l'on comparé à la guadeloupe la
martinique la martinique a eu la
montagne pelée en 1902 donc la ville de
saint pierre a été rasé et les archives
avait vu il ya moins d'argent
on va dire c'est delà de la réunion
d'action très bien préservés ni
totalement révolter ni totalement est
liée ni prono maillard en tant
qu'historien chercheurs a eu à coeur
avant tout de donner de l'humanité à ces
hommes et ces femmes qui ont su
reconstruire une communauté avec des
modes de culture qui leur permettaient
parfois échapper à des conditions de vie
inhumaines
même s'il est difficile d'y croire
lorsque l'on entend claquer le fouet du
châtiment un esclave pouvait parfois se
sentir libre et sans faire